great pants man yeah no problem this
movie is just like so much fun
I've been we've been talking about it
all night talking about it all morning
yeah saw it last night and I gotta say
do you like across the board everyone's
really enjoying this movie it looked
like it was a lot of fun to make how
much fun was it to be on set with you
know with all with everybody here
Crazy's hilarious no it was it was great
we we spend a lot of time together in
called Boston no one wanted to go back
to the trailers we stayed in the
basement of the house for many many
hours and we got to know each other and
share shared
really funny moments and personal and
stuff and we just had a great time and
Ryan is dip an angel the best director
you can wish for and yeah everyone was
like always in a good mood yeah cool so
much it really spoils your other movies
because not every movies like this yeah
you know again that the back type of
camaraderie bleeds into the performance
and that's that's when you feel
comfortable with the people you're
working with when you feel a friendship
with the people you're working with
that's when you feel the safety and the
comfort to take risks as an actor yeah
and when you take risks and when you
take chances and you don't feel judged
that's when you get the best stuff and
so so not only is it just enjoyable as a
person but it's really satisfying as an
actor yeah you guys must have seen it
several times by this point right when
you're watching it what do you like what
do you see what jumps out at you when
you're watching this movie like what
performance what scene oh my gosh god
there's so much to learn
yeah but I think it's just every time I
think how brilliant Ryan Johnson is yeah
well said as a director as a writer as a
you know orchestrating the whole thing
keeping the tone for everybody like
staying on it because a movie like this
one you can [ __ ] up so easily you
and actors it was so complicated like
his story wise and the whole twist isn't
the whole thing that we miss it like we
were just living in the moment this that
particular scene we're doing but we're
not looking at the big picture and he
had every single detail don't mind all
the time he was on cue so it was just
like the best rock perfectly said I
think riot it's like Ryan's work is
speaking yeah yeah
honor your you're in a few movies where
I mean your roles are good or phenomenal
everyone's gonna be seeing it I was
really talking about the things that
you're doing have you felt like this
sort of whirlwind yet of I guess like
Fame and everything that's going along
with it and have you been talking to him
about it like can you give me an advice
honestly I don't think I don't think
Anna would have booked this role unless
something about Anna innately yeah is
very present mm-hmm and very humble and
very thoughtful and and and all of that
stuff is what's gonna carry her through
to this next stage cuz this movie is
gonna change you
it's gonna change your landscape but but
nothing about her feels green or
inexperienced you know how she feels she
exudes a sort of um you just you feel
like yep this this woman belongs here
she belongs here she fits right in and
it's gonna you know she she doesn't need
any advice for me that's very cool hey
thank you so much guys